When I look at this ship,
it just speaks seedy to me.
There's something
suspicious about it.
Not only is it a reefer
with a Chinese name,
indicating that it could be
Chinese or Taiwanese, but now
all of a sudden it's
got a Bolivian flag,
and that's a flag
of convenience.
The irony, of course, about La
Paz and the flag of convenience
of Bolivia, is that it's
a landlocked country,
and it has no coastline.
I want to take a look around
because these reefers will also
have a log of all the
long-liners that came up to it
and try and shift with it.
Now imagine if all of a sudden
we can find Ping Shin 101.
I thought there'd
be no one on board.
I was wrong.
They may have a pilot
ladder they could toss down.
But it looks like right
now they're making a call.
This will likely
be for permission.
[non-english speech]
Whoever they were talking
to does the trick.
Good evening, gentlemen.
What's the story with this ship?
OK.
There have been cases
where reefers have
been used for narcotics
trafficking, typically
in South America.
Are you getting paid
well for this job?
At least what?
I'm hunting for the reefer's
log or any other clues
that could identify the
ships that came alongside.
Imagine all these longliners
that are coming in,
in this case the
Indian Ocean, all
rendezvousing with this
vessel and conducting
massive transhipments.
Longlining buoys.
It's pretty eerie down here.
I'm waiting to find either a
dead body or about 100 migrants
that are being smuggled.
There's no GA.
They ripped it off.
A GA's a General Assessment.
It's basically like the
floor plan, blueprint.
That's probably the
captain's quarters in there.
It's almost like he
left in a complete rush.
The reefer is a dead-end.
I need to know hoodlum's name,
and I still need a motive.